Metallica has been one of the world's
most popular live bands for decades now
the band is stuck at home canceling one
arena gig after another
instead of sitting behind the drums on
stage
Danish found Alaric sits at home and
drums his fingers let's call him up okay
I got my tea I got my water sorry it's
my my my two oldest boys are home from
college but my youngest is still doing
virtual school and it's on his lunch
break so I still had to uh just check
that he's finished his lunch and that
he'd put his dishes away and all these
things we have to do wait we should
start Lars thank you so much for taking
the time great to see you Fredrik once
again last time was we were in New York
exactly yeah
i reaiiy do remember and and I'm
thinking about that that trip because I
wonder if I'll ever get back there yeah
it's uh these are obviously unusual and
uncertain and obviously unprecedented
times you know I was communicating with
my friend and Denmark yesterday and you
know Denmark's and locked it you know
Denmark is is you know it locked to to
foreigner so obviously I have a Danish
passport my children had Danish
passports but my wife is a US citizen
what would happen if we all of a sudden
went to Denmark would she be able to get
in and you know all this you know so do
you miss that like that more than ever
let me tell you more than ever
obviously I'm very you know what I think
respectful is probably the right word of
the choices that were made in Denmark
and obviously no government maybe does
it all right but it seems like when the
Danes went into full
down a week or two before a lot of other
countries did and we read the Danish
newspapers here every day and my kids
get social media messages sent from
their friends in Denmark and people out
and the cafes and it's the end of May
and it's a great time to be outside and
people are starting to socialize and
mingle again so um with what's going on
in this country at the moment I really
miss Denmark yes we haven't left the
house
[Music]
March 10th 11th somewhere around there
obviously we've been out in the car a
couple times and but we haven't gotten
out of the car and so we're still in I
guess week 11 of a full quarantine and
you know the kids are back from New York
the two oldest kids were at college at
NYU and so an unexpected positive in all
this time of so much confusion and and
an uncertainty is to have all three boys
under the same roof again
and play you know music every day and
you know you play music with them with
your boys yeah we have a little studio
downstairs and so everybody's that
that's one of the most used of rooms of
the house so when you are playing with
your sons is there a lot of dads blaming
them they are so gifted all three of
them and and the two older ones who are
really I would say that from an ability
point of view they're way ahead of where
I am obviously I have the experience and
I I come at it from I'm really
interested in in being in a group you
know I'm a Danish person I like being in
a collective I like being in a game my
oldest son Miles
went to a Berklee School of Music up in
Boston for two years and so he as he's
got incredible chops as we say and he
can play I mean the craziest stuff but
what I try to talk to him about is
occasionally you know play like an AC
a song or great.you Tucson something
where the drums are more like of an
anchor and a song so it's they have a
different approach than I do but you
know my they're great jazz players they
play pop music they play rock music they
play fusion they can play they can play
anything and so they're really really
gifted in a very on a wide palette and
and what I was doing at their time was
just it was that wide what what about I
mean talking about dads I can see a
picture behind you and I guess it's a
painting of your own dad oh yeah
somebody a friend of mine gave this to
me and so you know my dad is 90 he's
gonna be 92 this year and he's just
across the bay over in Tiburon he writes
every day he paints and he's working on
a few more books and working on all
kinds of projects of the fact that
there's nobody there to bother him as is
I think he's secretly kind of happy
about that tell me tell me about
Metallica these days because I mean even
before all this happened with the
coronavirus you were you you had a sort
of forced break from from touring tell
me what happened I mean so yeah I mean
we've been going so the last record when
I was on your show came out in 16 and
and we we played all the way up till
September of last year so that was over
three years we were supposed to go to
Australia James went into to rehab once
again to deal with some of his issues
fill this thing here yeah say yeah so we
unfortunately missed our tour in
Australia and he is back now and he's at
home and we're just starting in the last
on a four for four weeks maybe we uh we
connected again I mean we've been
obviously connecting but we connected
creatively and now
we're sort of the in discovery mode I
think it's a good way to say it we are
sending ideas to each other via email
India zoom and sort of make music in
these unusual situations so we're
looking at it it's it's an interesting
time obviously we have maybe 15
appearances live concerts this year on
the calendar obviously at this time we
don't know if any of them will happen
you know in the middle of March it's
like Oh in a month from now in two
months from now everything will be back
to quote normal and now ten eleven weeks
later we realize that there may never be
a normal again it may opposite have to
be a new normal a new way of looking do
you see a future where it's possible
that you will never play an arena again
I don't know if I'm at that point yet I
understand the difficulties of of what's
ahead of us it's it's hard to believe
that with a vaccine and with um you know
I am NOT talking three months from now
six months oh now I'm talking about five
years from now I will would severely
doubt that there will never be a time
again where people will perform in an
arena that's hard to fathom but it may
not be for quite some time we're trying
to figure you know we're looking at
things right now and there are some
options as you know down in Denmark
they've had to drive in concerts and and
you know we're looking at options with
virtual you know maybe we play and those
concerts get broadcast at different
places when we've always kind of joked
okay we've joked you know when you know
along the way you know you're sitting
there and you've been on the road for
two years and you just want to go home
it's like one day maybe there'll be a
version of touring where we're at home
and the audience comes to us and I mean
look at us I mean I must home you're at
home that's how it works now yeah I used
to have a talk show
a big smile on your face and so why I
mean we I think as humans we always will
try to make the most of the situation
and I try to just go well I got my kids
here you know you and I are talking the
sun is shining outside in San Francisco
and we make the most of it tell me do
you have like meetings like zoom or or
teams meetings in in the group the four
of you yes we do yes we uh we have a the
weekly zoom connect and now that so
we've been doing that for yeah I mean
basically since it started for ten ten
eleven weeks or since it started in
America so we get together once a week
on zoom for a couple hours and catch up
the good thing about that catching up is
we really just talk about how we're
doing in and what we don't sit and talk
about Metallica for hours and hours but
now that we've started exchanging some
ideas and and it's great I mean it's uh
it's nice to be in touch it's nice to be
part again like a set up of that group
and and I look forward to the creative
the opportunities of my head so what
would be the difference between a normal
Metallica album and Quarantine Metallica
album if it were to be to that kind of
album so far at least the the sonic
sound or the sonic side of it and and
the practical elements are surprisingly
uh they're in surprisingly good shape
actually so now we just got to figure
out how much we can create without being
in the same space you know the
difference obviously between bands like
ourselves or any other band you know
people that are still bands like the
u2's of the world or the Red Hot Chili
Peppers a col player Iron Maiden or
whatever is that you really are bands
and you rely on on the group format to
really move everything forward so unlike
if you're a solo artist and it's just
you and your guitar whatever so it's
it's a different thing but um - meaning
it sounds to me it sounds like this al
on the way uh I would say yes under way
it's it's certainly uh I think it's
exciting to look at it certainly you
know for us I'm happy that I'm
reconnecting with my fellow bandmates
and um I hope that we can play some
shows this year between me and you if
you promise not to tell anybody I'm
doubtful that we'll play any shows this
year but the fact that we're a Metallica
I can't you know I mean we're 39 years
into this and um like we sort of joke
most of the time we're just getting
started
and all our best years are ahead of us
so uh you know listen it'sit's a it's
another good day to be alive even with
the challenges that are upon the world
and we'll try to do the best we can i I
think that you'll get through this
somehow and of course that you you you
won't starve any of you but what about
the next Metallica and I mean some years
ago CD sales dropped because of Napster
which you fought and also streaming in
general and now ticket sales dropped or
disappeared if I were to be pessimistic
I would say this is the end of rock and
roll I mean how should they think oh
it's not the end of rock and roll it's
it's temporarily there's a temporary
pause but obviously as you can see if
you follow what everybody's doing in the
musical community lots of people
everyday are making music from their
homes sharing it from their bedrooms
sharing it from their living room
sharing it from their basement share it
in any way they can
and although to get paid they need to
get paid I mean ticket sales pays of
course and and listen I don't have the
answer for that right now
I I don't think that there's anybody
that doesn't think that at some point
there will be a version that will pay
artists that need to support themselves
what version it will be when it gets
back on on its feet we don't know but
the end o rock-and-roll they've been
trying to end rock and roll for 5060
years since Elvis started shaking his
hips and Chuck Berry and Little Richard
and everybody else came up with this
incredible new force of nature and the
mid 50s and they still haven't killed a
rock and roll and I don't believe komen
will either Loras I I just wonder
thinking back on your your lost or
having looking down at that mosh pit of
people enjoying enjoying Metallica can
you get sentimental
I'm obviously I would say more than
anything grateful for the fact that
almost 40 years in Metallica still means
this much to so many people so I tried
to rather than get sentimental about it
or nostalgic I tried to be grateful and
appreciative and um I am the number one
Metallica fan in the world and it's just
you know a child is an only child
growing up in Denmark and wanting to
belong to something bigger than myself
being in metallic and being part of a
worldwide music community just gives me
a sense of identity and that's the
greatest thing about this journey for
almost 40 years later Lars
thank you so much and please stay safe
okay until we see you again thank you so
much bye-bye
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe
you